hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and I don't
want to waste your time with banter
today because we have a very special
guest we're very happy to have Wynton
Marsalis join us on the podcast if you
are in any sense a jazz fan Wynton
Marsalis is the proverbial guy who needs
no introduction
he's been acclaimed as a trumpet player
of course but also as a composer a
bandleader and also an educator and an
ambassador for jazz music worldwide he's
the winner of multiple Grammy Awards he
was the first jazz musician indeed the
first non classical musician to win a
Pulitzer Prize countless honorary
degrees national awards etc he's
recorded a huge number of albums as a
leader of small ensembles big bands and
in collaboration with a diverse group of
people from Willie Nelson to Eric
Clapton to traditional musicians around
the world he's also the founder and
leader of Jazz at Lincoln Center which
joins things like the Metropolitan Opera
and the New York Philharmonic in
residence at Lincoln Center not only
that but he is a classical musician who
both composes and plays trumpet with
symphony orchestras he won a Grammy for
that too so you get the point
- Wynton Marsalis is arguably the most
important figure alive in jazz today and
certainly enormous ly influential in how
we think about music he and I got to
meet at a nice event called Kent
presents this is an ideas festival in
Connecticut sponsored by Ben and Donna
Rosen and we hit it off immediately he's
very curious guy he wanted to know about
physics and things like that I want to
know about jazz so we have a wide
ranging bouncy conversation and if you
don't like jazz if you've never heard of
Wynton Marsalis no problem I would still
recommend listening to this episode this
is not one of those conversations where
we just sort of name-drop our favorite
musicians or artists from the past or
from the present Wynton Marsalis is an
opinionated guy he always has been
that's what I've been one of his
trademarks all along and he gives us
some of his opinions not just about
music but about the state of the world
the state of the country the state of
Education in the United States we talk
about
physics we talk about time and quantum
mechanics this is your chance to spend
an hour with a brilliant creative person
with an open fertile mind we had a great
time and I hope you will too
so let's go
[Music]
wynton marsalis welcome to the mindscape
podcast right this is such a pleasure
Sean thank you so I understand that your
first paying gig was as a funk musician
is that right that's right that's right
this is in the 1970s this is the
bell-bottoms the big hair the whole bit
that's right early early in that chair
we played a elementary school dance an
elementary school dance
all right recompense for this tea cafe
yeah we happy we have paid a hundred
dollars it was five of us so it's $20 a
person and look what were you playing we
played it was just stuffed it was on a
radio at that time but we had learned we
learned but like maybe 15 songs or 20
songs or 20 songs in three minutes it
was a dance three hours so all right so
we played the 20 songs we're like okay
that's it we still have two hours to go
so we just play those again in a loop
take it so dance move it over again so
we always laugh about that about this
job but there is something special about
jazz right I mean what what in your mind
is what makes jazz special I think that
the three fundamentals of the music a
hunk improvisation to it to some type of
grid so you you you can improvise but
you have some restraint right the swing
which means you're improvising with
other people and there are things that
govern how you are will will will
interact with each other but those those
those things you also choose them so if
you're a heavy swinger you choose to be
in the groove it and you choose to give
some points over to people if you're not
you don't and then the Blues which is an
optimism in spite of all evidence to the
contrary
aha so explain that and it's like in a
in the words of a blues I went down to
the railroad put my head on the track
uh-huh went down the river put my head
on the track when that train came along
I snatched my fool head back so there's
something in there so the Blues is sort
about living through life right not
giving up is living is about an optimism
is not naive right right and to say
we're about swing in particular because
you know I've had
talks with musician friends I'm not a
musician myself I appreciate the music
very much but you know swing is is you
know there's other genres of music that
improvise the Blues is it a John role by
itself but swing is something that is
unique as physics you know is relational
right and it's quantifiable mm-hmm this
is it's the reconciliation of opposites
so if you look at swing as a concept
whatever it takes for you to get from
the I consciousness to the we
consciousness okay it's swinging
now when you embrace that in such a way
that you're in a groove and you make all
these the little adjustments that are
required to make to to to not just
endure another person or to tolerate
them right but you embrace them then
you're swinging yeah so when you look at
it as a concept it is a six rhythm teen
teen teen teen two one two three four
five six one two three four five six one
two three four five six against a four
rhythm one two three four one two three
four Dean Dean Dean Dean Dean Dean now
on a micro-level where it shows up is if
you start to play fast so if you go you
can't go epic epic epic epic and you
have to go to lay low you shuffling yeah
so that's a two and A three also so
instead of it being a little it's
difficult yeah to come to negotiate the
feeling of though that I'd and even at
the same time it's the the swing is the
base which is the lowest pitch played on
in for on every beat match with the
drums this in six which the cymbal is
the highest pitch and the pitch that you
can hear the most so you have all these
extremes
sounds like the drummer has a tough job
the drum has a tough jobs president okay
you can just choose to just Bowl
everybody over but great drummers don't
see a great drummers kind they use their
power very intelligently and sparingly
and it sounds like it's about I mean so
much music is about tension in some
sense right I mean it's a competition
between what you expect the sort of
natural easy rhythm pattern for
a little bit of what doesn't quite
belong it drives you forward right right
how would I'm interested in how you
would see that yeah in relation to some
something some concepts that you work on
where you have opposite things they come
together and you say man these two
things are together I never would have
thought these things come together yeah
it's all over the place I mean physics
science right is driven by what we don't
understand we try to leap into the
places that we don't yet understand
science professional scientists don't
spend their time doing homework problems
but the college students do and so what
is the what is the way to make progress
it's to pinpoint two things that you
both think are true but they don't agree
with each other right and that's where
all progress comes from so the big one
right now in physics is we have quantum
mechanics we have gravity and they don't
play well together and they're in
tension right and we're trying to figure
out it's one of them better is one of
them more fundamental or is it we got to
start all over again and it's sort of a
source of creativity a little bit right
and a jazz seems to be much about
creativity
yes about creativity at the point of
impact I was also interested in your
comments about time because in jazz you
live in the future you you you you
progress from the future to the past
that's like life yeah in the future but
you're going into the past you're moving
forward into the past you know moving
forward into the future now you're gonna
have to break that down for me okay you
you are in the future like now futures
pass okay so we're we're all in the
future good future in that
then we pass through the present into
our cognitive than at present which is
then past
okay so jazz as a mastery of a moment of
present is right so the future becomes
what you think may perhaps happen with
the form at a given in a given space and
time right and the challenge of jazz
when you're actually playing it is how
can I deal with it with all of the
entropic moments of this present and
give it organization and logic and give
it organization and logic and form with
a group of other people who have no idea
of what they're gonna play until they
play it well that that's I wanted to ask
you about this I mean so there's the
individual improvising and there's the
group let's just do the individual first
that's probably easier to wrap our
brains around right I mean do you go
into an improvisation to the solo with a
plan or is it literally right there what
are you feeling I never do that yeah
every person is different I like to be
present so I don't have a plan
my one plan is to take the mattock
material and develop it in some type of
interesting way huh
to me is that the chords or the melody
the court the courts or the playing
field uh-huh it's like a football field
yes you know yeah
that's the arena so you know where the
football field aside guy sidelines
the harmonies progressed in a certain
way and there's some alterations but
they are the harmonies and they're laid
out in time so like you look at a clock
use it was 12 numbers and you know where
you are would you look at those hands
you know that's our harmonic form is you
know where you are by the progression of
harmonies and you also learn you have to
get back to you know when you get back
to the top but the top may be different
but the harmony will the harmony is
basically the same but it's because
courts have different root notes them
and they're also a way to substitute
chords it's kind of like the directions
to your home you give me 50 sets of
directions that incorporate different
streets yeah if the general direction
will be all the different ways you can
express an equation with different
numbers we're playing on that playing
field so now we know that then we have
to be in time and the concept of time
and jazz is probably the most kind of
physics related right because you're not
in time like 1 2 3 4 time in what we
call swing time mm-hmm and it's not
being on time it's being in time and
that time is like a wave because
everybody is talking and pulling at it
right yeah as you when you mentioned how
important it is in physics that's
exactly right like so much of physics
about waves and the resonance the
beating together and interference when
they're going in different directions
right what do I'm more interested in
what does does the degree of
interference determine something about
the wave or does a wave just continue
the way it is yeah it can be either way
right so I think that physicists love to
start with the simplest thing first
right so the simplest thing is yeah the
waves if you have two different waves
and they're coming in to the same place
they
to their own individual thing and then
they keep going and at that moment they
might interfere or constructively
interfere which is a sort of
contradiction in terms what it means
they add up together right so we teach
our students that first and then the
next thing we teach is well what if
these ways are talking to each other
right like what if they interact with
each other and these days we think our
best theories of the world are quantum
field theories where the world is this
collection of fields pervading all of
space and what we think of as particles
are vibrations in these fields right and
if you make a new particle that's
because you the in fact the analogy I
use is if someone's playing a piano
and there's another piano in the room
the other piano starts humming a little
bit right that's how you create new
particles in particle physics kind of
sympathetic vibration exactly that
that's right yes that's exactly what
jazz is like I like a lot of times you
can anticipate what somebody is going to
play or you you can you can you could
feel them a certain way and sometimes
they do the opposite and that's okay too
yeah cuz it's really a like super
conversations no wrong no well yeah you
know there are actually no wrong notes
they're only there only awkward moments
in non resolutions in lack of confidence
enough you have to hear your way out of
problems right it's kind of giving the
conversation somebody is oh yeah awkward
moment even with awkward kind of ear but
uh it's for the is fascinating when you
get a lot of people improvise it who
really can play how they all hear and
interpret the moments cuz the successive
moments of crisis there's always a
crisis right
every moment is a crisis and wound up
when the band stops it's a break and
only you play then it's really a crisis
for you because you have to maintain a
momentum and identity and then I do know
they're gone then they come back in so
you you know our thing is really about
mastery of time and the mastery of time
is an individual thing on one level but
in the jazz sense in the swing sense as
mastery of the fluctuations of time with
other people right yeah and that's where
swing comes in you know you're against
the obvious regular beat right you you
have the obvious regular beat is a
constant that you all know but the swing
is
you're all of yours interpretation of
that constant right and how you can
negotiate that constant and make you
feel good and you know sometimes these
solos can get pretty long you go for a
long time how how much of it is
conscious would you say like can you
even remember the solo that you played
no you can't remember but is conscious
like when you speak is conscious okay
like you weren't using notes when you
would talk when you lecture the other
day right but you knew what you were
talking about the general outline it was
gonna say but I had a plan going in
right and well the form gives us our
plans yeah so when I said I don't have a
plan the form gives you some type of
plan it's a and then I tend to take
things from musicians I'm playing with
Mike when they play stuff I play things
I think that uh my solos I try to really
think about construction okay what do
you by that I mean how am I gonna get
from this point by turning phrases
around of the or how am I going to make
a cohesive and coherent statement be
telling a story tell how am I gonna tell
that story beginning middle and you can
follow it right that's you know how can
I get all these little subplots and
interesting things and change the
emotions of different moments in a add
things and it is usually in this group
context right and as impressed and
overwhelmed as I am with a master
improviser I'm even more impressed that
people can do it together right and how
much of it is you know I see on the
bandstand you know people looking at
each other like the players and how much
communication is a lot is it planned out
is it normally just you sense it no
there's so much communication and that's
what I love the most about playing is
playing with other people just so much
communication like shifting beads or you
created in your solo
does that really record you want to play
where are we okay hopefully a river
there is so much of it it's like it's so
innocent very intense right it's like an
intense an intense emotional and mind
game what other people in this is all
benevolent like as none of it is because
the swing is a reference and it makes
you if you want to swing it makes you
have a constant that you
agree on yeah okay it's like kinda like
what the Constitution is supposed to be
you guys you have to agree on something
yeah something has to have meaning in
order for us to have a meaningful
dialogue and there's to be some arbiter
something that we both the ryokan list
otherwise is just noise right it was
just let's not sell the stock kids
that's right you know let's yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I mean jazz is you
mentioned in the we just for the podcast
listeners out there we just got finished
with some remarks that went and made
here on stage and you also mentioned the
the American nosov it right I mean
there's something and for better for
worse right mostly for better but jazz
is part of America and America is part
of jazz well I don't I don't think for
worse the worst is a part of better yeah
okay you know you can't it's like what
you were saying when you give us the
examples of entropy one one does nothing
then there's some things Denis you don't
have one of all one thing right if
everything is too simple and nothing
interesting has happened right and
that's that's the famous Shakespeare to
be or not to be yes right it's gonna be
one of those or maybe right like you
know and all the kind of greatest
artists have that kind of dichotomies
unity they understand that's why
Shakespearean villain is so great oh
yeah he understands it something is
something Noble in this villain there's
a humanity in the villain and I kind of
simplistic way of looking at the world
does not work well for democracy mm-hm
and jazz is it came from the most
maligned group people that have been
slaves but they didn't play jazz when
they were in slavery they play jazz when
they became free and freedom is
something that has not been guaranteed
to people in the world throughout time
now if you go trial time most groups of
people have been dominated or they have
been beaten it's not to be subjugated to
the will of a person or group of people
it's not something that's only about the
United States of America most of the
greatest heroes that we celebrate our
military heroes that defeated people and
engaged in absolute murder concubine
itch and and slavery that's what it like
I talked about it that's what he will
conquer in PA
and you know America is a hope to to the
hope that we have to change and it's hot
as difficult and it's challenging and we
at this moment appear to not be up to
that challenge but when we actually
understand what the rest of what was
going on in the world and that they're
guaranteed democracy and even the
thought that there is equality it's not
something that's guaranteed your sight
is not guaranteed to win no you know
there's a lot of power and that by that
I don't mean in a fear of another nation
I mean the fear of an ideology which is
to hell with these people which is what
has dominated the world most of the time
and he has even been dominant in our
country's leadership if not its people
but a democracy is a place where you can
lose an election and give up power
willingly right you don't usually pose
to you're supposed to you also yeah
you're also supposed to agree on a set
of principles would you say that jazz is
in some sense a democratic form of music
compared to others absolutely no
question about it in every way we could
we could okay I could take you down the
Constitution in the the the separation
of powers and and all the things that
are the foundation of what we do the
ability to amend to make to amend the
Constitution and the Constitution being
a very simple frame document this this
shorter than every other state
constitution and the repetitiveness of
the Constitution yeah from the federal
government to the state government to
the to local government but when you
don't have an agreement on the the the
the humanity of other people then used
to subvert the Constitution yeah in some
sense I mean this is what liberal
democracy is all about I had a podcast
about liberal democracy the idea you
know you don't have to agree with your
fellow citizens about values necessarily
you can disagree about fundamental
things but there has to be something
shared right there has to be something
shared I agree with and you you base
everything on that and a bunch of
players up there improvising together
have to be the same
and many too many times we are not what
is happen when I'm music and many times
one person was solo all night as five
people were solo forever
monitors on the best and that allowed it
into people were playing all with them
in it a the strongest on the bandstand
dominating the base turns amp up to 15
and then it's very difficult to play the
music and then what another thing that
happens after that is slavery and the
slavery becomes this system has too much
freedom in it let me figure out how to
repeat things over and over again so
that we do away with somebody's freedom
and that's the direction we will go in
if we listen to if we check out the way
systems are slowly beginning to dominate
everything and our systems mackeral
thinkers are very powerful you know we
don't realize that when you play a
system a very intelligently designed
system out to the furthest extreme of
its efficiency many of these systems
don't include people has to be something
else that's the machine it's just a
machine it is just we don't we don't
need you then after we don't need you we
don't want to see you and so you're
you're saying we can think of jazz as a
little bit of protest against this
tendency when it's at its time even in
jazz right in any form of art you can
always denigrate into something right
where it's a great man with an ego yeah
a lot of it though a lot of the tenants
of in the best of it the recorded
history of it and it jazz is also not
anti the Machine it's not we're Against
the Machine we're against the abuse of
tools and we are we are for the basic
principles of our way of government and
our music has a history that
demonstrates that Duke Ellington's
Orchestra demonstrated that petty
government orchestra demonstrated that
Dave Brubeck's ensemble John Coltrane
Art Blakey the jazz masters we have
elected people Charles Mingus and they
were also able to express that yeah it
did express it so it's not something
we're speculating on yeah yeah and so
what I mean
jazz has a interesting position in
history in the United States and right
now right I mean there's not a lot of
radio stations out there right play by
primarily jazz I mean you've been as
influential as anybody in not just
keeping jazz alive we keeping it vibrant
and making sure that people are educated
about it how important is that to you um
is very important for us to be educated
about our country we've stopped civics
you know we have to understand it that
for democracy to work we have to be
rabid about education right rabbit not
about propaganda because I'm not a kind
of left right person I laugh at all of
that because for me it's like it's like
subterfuge you know it's like you and
your friend
start a fight in the in a store and
another one of your friends is going for
the cash register now all you do is get
a black and a white friend call each
other name everybody is looking at it
yeah that's all fake like it's not
people people are making money in a
exploiting the one of the biggest
problems we have and it happens in jazz
as the greatest players help to
sacrifice for lesser players like the
great Art Blakey allowed me to learn on
his Bandstand I wasn't bringing that
anything to him he had to be willing to
sacrifice for me to learn when you get
the most educated class waging war on
the uneducated class man you have a hard
time you're not gonna get the same thing
that you get with the Ku Klux Klan or
somebody shout and you call the people
names you can get contracts you get the
subprime loan scandal you can get all
the things that you see there are
systems that play out on people who
can't assess their position their
position in space mmm-hmm I mean were
you I probably know the answer to this
but how much of this was in your brain
when you were 12 years old and first
learning played the trumpet you know a
lot of it
yeah I didn't know it was about playing
the trumpet but my mom and my dad were
very conscious cuz they're my father's
jazz musician and you just so everyone
knows you're from New Orleans no from
New Orleans guy and uh my mother was
very conscious about reading this
staying on top of stuff being engaged my
father's very conscious so I would
always just be around listening to all
of them talk uh-huh and I didn't
understand of course what I understand
now but I knew that you needed to know
about the country you needed to follow
things you needed to be and that was in
a time of consciousness you know I was a
kid through the sixties
so people were conscious yeah there was
something that word was talked about
right talked at the pop music was
conscious even if it was just Stevie
Wonder's music Marvin Gaye's music
what's going on for just two Everage
kind of citizeness out it it doesn't
have an artist father or mother they
were still engaged in making things
better and being a part of a larger
thing right we lost that momentum of
course over time because it's difficult
to maintain that level of engagement
with each other without being predatory
mmm-hmm we celebrate predators
well we it's natural to sort of devolve
into conflict right like we try to talk
to each other and try to disagree again
this is something that I hope the
podcast helps to spread the idea we can
disagree still be friends go out for the
beer after water but it becomes harder
and harder especially in a very shouty
age a shouty ideological age that is not
respectful of any fact it's also true
that is right there has to be some fact
that we agree on we're in Louisiana okay
that's a fact let's just thought with
that yeah and that's why I try to tell
explain things in a human context like
the musicians I knew whether I ordered
or argued with them or not when we talk
to each other we're talking about human
things right not my philosophy about
this style of music it was my momma is
dying or you know my son told me the
other day or can you believe that I was
I always I had dyslexia and I was always
ashamed you know I mean it's oh
absolutely I mean when you try to be a
communicator of science even though
science is based on facts and you should
all agree them if you really want to get
things across you have to be likable you
have to relate it to people's interests
right you know people care about what
what matters for their lives that's not
surprising at all but that's what you're
wonderful at my god when I first talked
to you you're very approachable I start
asking you about entanglement and will
the universe just continue to expand
yeah and you started give me very
concrete kind of breakdowns of what
something was in a way that I could
understand it and you're friendly I
think it matters you know not obviously
to give credit where credit is due
my wife gets a lot of credit yes I'm a
scientist by training she's a writer
by training so she's helped me and in
the communication skills but so you went
from this kid in a sort of household
where all these ideas were talked about
in a very musical household obviously
playing all sorts of things now you're
the director of Jazz at Lincoln Center
and that's a responsibility right that's
not I mean how do you think of that role
I mean you're you're a musician you play
the trumpet you're a composer but then
you're also an ambassador right yeah I'm
I'm honored to be in that role you know
I mean I I love people I like to talk
about the music and to be a part of
people's lives and to to recognize other
people jazz Lincoln Center is a our our
our basic tenets of what we do we we
entertain we educate and we advocate for
jazz through performance through
education and through advocacy we try to
bring people together around the music
we have very simple kind of down-home
type of welcome vibration that we have
no generation gap about that yeah we
stress no generation gap no segregation
and all of our music is modern uh-huh
we're all separate in the kind of time
periods we believe the music does have
fundamentals we don't believe everything
this horn is jazz yeah but we're not
against things that are not jazz we just
are in favor of jazz and we've been
blessed to work with women we've
collaborated with so many musicians of
different cultures have played with yeah
you know some of your favorites you know
just to just tell you a couple of
stories one is a great master drummer
from Ghana
yeah cool body he passed away we I did a
piece it can called Congo Square with
him it took me 10 years to write this
piece I use playing rhythms I couldn't
figure out because his style means they
play in two times at once
I'm counting and doing all Western
that's not well and then a kid who I had
taught when he was younger grew old
enough he started playing when I
orchestrated his name is Carlos Enriquez
and he's from the afro-latin tradition
so he grew up playing on cloud base so
we're close enough like he's really like
my little brother so he's always in mine
so I said man why is this sad and we put
it on he started to interpret like I
want to cloud leaves you doing this this
is where one is is what we need to do
you could translate we could translate
for me so he translated for me and
Yaqoob wants funny stories he was
playing a rhythm he said I brother this
is a royal rhythm royal rhythm I said it
don't sound royal to me
I'm American and he said that is why you
will never play it correctly well Eddy
up to that you jump right and Kurt
Missoula was the conductor's New York
Philharmonic he had grown up in Germany
during the period of the Nazis and he
asked me to write a piece for the
Philharmonic and he said he wanted the
piece to celebrate humanity and people
coming together and he told me I never
forget he said you have no idea of how
thin the the that the veneer is and how
it could hold and people people will
cheerlead the very opposite he said and
you be mindful of how how fragile all of
this is and when you write this music be
cognizant of the fragility and be strong
in an indictment of those things that
are against human beings well music
speaks directly to our emotions right
and for better that's for better for
worse they can they can excite us for
the good things and you know it can be
used as propaganda right for the less
good things I mean what do you think
about the state of jazz today if that's
not too grandiose a question well I
think most of the young musicians are
demoralized and mainly commercial music
they're interested it's like the state
of our country we are we are consumed
with rampant commercialism and a
materialism is destroying our human
connections as our front it's
embarrassing because it just kind of
opened corruption and we have to get on
track and we're a long way away it's not
because of the president he's of course
a signing symbol of it but it's not
because of that it predates long pretty
long before that and I don't like when
it's reduced to him because it keeps us
from addressing the issue
there's deeper things going much deeper
than one guy much deeper much deeper and
we have taught it to our kids we've used
them as a market they're now being sold
to exploit it from a very young age they
can't defend themselves we're not
defending them and music is a large part
of the exploitation
now pornography is a fact of kids lives
and it leads them into their rituals of
courtship in a development of course I'm
from older generations I don't
understand all of the nuances of it the
tinder and everything but I mean no it's
not even so much a specific thing it's
just how many how many acts you can see
right in every generation lives in a
different world yeah where everybody
says that but you know it's like you're
working on a heart attack till you have
it you tell somebody man you have a
heart attack to say I haven't have one
okay you haven't had one but there's
gonna come a point where the kind of
descent you're gonna reach as there's a
thought that because they're always
there's always misinformation and the
conflation of fact and there's always a
kind of alarmist the past is better if
you touched on that - yeah I I love one
thing you say it I took my notes I could
get on my phone but you said there there
are more it's the gist of it is that it
you they're more they're fewer plausible
paths then there are possible futures
exactly that what you see I love that's
right yeah you know so the tendencies to
always think the past was so glorious
and I'm not coming from there at all
yeah before we're thinking yeah I'm just
I'm just saying that we uh kids are not
a market right and in our our
celebration of the marketing of money
has has damaged our sense of the the
primacy of humanity and that that should
be first it should be first in higher
education left or right it's not from
the right and it's not from the left is
from all of it and they're starting to
starting to rot and we got to wake up
and you but stuff you know you got our
living if you want to be a professional
musician being a jazz musician is hard
right you know let it be hard yeah you
told the story about your father could
you could you uh yeah tell this that I
grew up watching my father just struggle
and not make money you know he was
always playing for three and four people
five eight people in a row man I just
wandered over all these years man why do
you keep doing this and he said
somebody's got to do this why you know
people need if nobody's here that people
don't want it it's like what why
music has meaning but to who nobody is
it means something to me and sometimes
you have to be the one to say the
Constitution has meaning I am going to
be civil and I'm not gonna just let the
fact that I might spare me some money
affect my ideology or the fact that
where our our somebody was given a tax
break means that we should have policies
they could put people unjustly in jail
and it's not just a problem of those
people we're all those people that kind
of superconsciousness we we don't have
that type of leadership not cuz of the
president now I get it yeah and and and
in no way of my supporter of the
President's agenda social agenda in no
way you can't come from my background
and support using people Mexican people
and you know Arabs and black people you
can't support that
coming from where I come from but once
again I don't want to pin that pin a
national problem on a figure that is
actually doing the bidding of a large
part of the nation yeah and one of the
ways I think about this is how hard it
is to be generous right to be generous
to someone who we don't agree with how
easy it is to declare someone bad or
evil because they're not on our side and
how hard it is to work together with
people who are against us in some ways
oh yeah to get in there like you USN to
get in there with someone who has a
different point of view who can help you
sometimes you have a figure that you
cannot work with which may be the case
in this instance but for our nation the
divisiveness that attacks all of us
regardless of who the president is on an
atomic level we're responsible and
you've written you know you you've
composed many things and you obviously
have a quite a discography and sometimes
instrumentals sometimes there's words in
there and your words are pretty
unsparing you don't you don't mess
around
right no I don't I'm very direct you
know I try to be as honest as I can be
you know I kept as honest as I can be at
the time with the information I have and
everything is not right but it's as
right as I can feel when I write a piece
I think is serious and I don't care who
doesn't like it and I don't mind him
expressing that they don't like it
that's one of the strengths of our way
of life we should all strive for that
attitude I would love to be able to do
that it's it's what I try to do yeah
yeah we can't stop them yeah yeah and do
you see the younger people today are
they is there a jazz following out there
I don't I don't see that much of a
following with the younger people
because the young people are marketing
we're trying to sell things to them and
they are largely their sexuality has
been co-opted by by visual images and
now jazz about music and his quality you
have to take the time and we are not we
are not interested in teaching our
younger people how to take time and to
be a part of our way of life I do think
there's room for optimism in the sense
that technology etc has given people
more room to be creators to be you know
innovators themselves is that too
optimistic Mike I know I was aiming
Dixie no no I think I think there's
always a younger pitch a lot of students
and I always tell them what they're
gonna do I cannot I cannot see that I
give them some information that they can
use and what they gonna do but they have
to do what they are going to do and I
try to the biggest thing I see in my
students is the ones who are really
creative suffer the greatest failure of
optimism in a belief it's easy for them
to be really cynical and just saying I'm
just gonna make some money or I'm just
gonna dumb my music down or I just I
need to get a public like I can't just
be out here I don't I guess it's hard to
keep their belief strengthened so that
they can be innovative as musicians
right because the music they hearing a
lot of it is is like wallpaper like it's
being made by by a person on a computer
and it's it's not like a democratic
music is not people are not even in this
room at the same time they're making an
artifact right which is a can be very
creative human beings are creative in
anything we do it doesn't doesn't matter
for jazz musicians
is not optimal for us because our music
is very much human you're sneaking looks
over at the bass player and the drummer
right you know what's is what changes
the is about it's about human beings and
how we interact not about our tools that
we have developed I mean you play
obviously a lot of Lincoln Center you
played large concerts but there is
something romantic about being in with
one or two other people up there in a
tiny stage right yeah I love it but I
love in any context okay just you know
it is of course when you're in a small
place I guess also for me is how I grew
up so a small place with no people in it
I'm at home I get down to the 2:30 in
the morning that's what I do with jazz
dinosaurs that's what I do and but it's
not all you do you also been very
successful in the classical music world
and how do you mentally sort of make
that leap or do you even see a
difference between jazz and classical
music it is a difference a 10 and
procedure in training in the style of
music but classical music is one of the
foundations of jazz so I also love that
music I don't play as much but I do
write pieces for orchestras and I use
but the experience I have playing for
many years I love playing an orchestra
playing all the great are careful pieces
and I do feel that that that is that's a
library that is so phenomenal that we we
sell that library short I always wonder
well never forget about the power of
this library so what did some of your
favorite classical pieces man I you know
I can't I could start with any symphony
of hiding and all the Beethoven
symphonies Beethoven string quartets all
a box music is great doesn't even matter
what you listen to
Palestrina Pope Marcellus Mass I'm just
I like the name but the unbelievable
piece Bartok concerto for Orchestra
Stravinsky any whatever you take your
pick they get e it doesn't make I mean
you can just go on and on and on it's
fantastic Brahms fantastic library
mother Strauss i just I'm very thankful
that I was able to develop the ability
to hear that library in high school
because when I started I couldn't hear
that kind of music at all and I thought
only for white people but to be able to
overcome that ignorance and that
prejudice and actually listen to the
music it's akin to a person who doesn't
know what jazz is
like if you can get to where you can
hear John Coltrane's musica Thelonious
Monk Duke Ellington Count Basie and
Eunice our struggle you have to work on
it but if you get to where you can hear
it it's so many unbelievable riches and
our classical music is manages
Shostakovich Shostakovich several
symphony if you can get to wait you can
hear that I strongly encourage you to
develop a taste for it because these
were very very serious people who
sacrificed a great deal for music and
had extreme insight into the nature of
many things and there's also sort of a I
mean especially if you're a kid there's
just a coolness barrier right like when
I first started listening to jazz sure
Miles Davis John Coltrane Charlie Parker
and it was years later that I started
listening at Duke Ellington I was like
where if I do it okay you know what's
happening yeah I was like that too I
didn't like Duke big-band music man like
Gerald oh you're right that's like your
grandparents except the same experience
with it and on with that kind of quality
music I feel of any tradition it could
be tango music I was I was listening to
us my man like I always forget people's
names when I was checking out my my tank
orchestras from the 1950s and 60s and I
was like man isn't it is and Brazilian
music of more sir Santos they're there
these figures and every culture that
that uh they were deeply engaged with
the music of them of their culture yeah
and they created things that when we
touched him Horatio saw gone is the
person lost by an entangled music and
when you when you include them into your
listening they they lift you yeah and do
you incorporate classical elements into
your jazz composing and vice versa
sure yeah yes it's only it's only
natural you would use contrapunto
elements that come from classical music
harmonic devices orchestration Oh
techniques why not would you tell much
of physical universe now I know it's all
the waves but would there be the kind of
improvisation that you do in jazz that
would sneak its way not with pianists
right yeah when you when you write for
classical musicians an orchestra I know
but I had an idea for for another
the other day of uh how could you get
everybody to improvise not in a
vocabulary this jazz like in a rhythmic
vocabulary and then a non harmonic vocab
you get out how I want to write a
symphony that's all with a lot of
improvisation in it hmm you have to heat
feel figure out the improvisation not in
the jazz context right if you use the
same forms but you have to give the
different sections because you have 70
people you know it's well like we said
improv uh improvising multiple people at
once actually you said something earlier
today that was fascinating about just
you know two trumpet players up on stage
and the phrase used over and over again
was sharing space right and that's
that's the trick right yeah it's a
shared space it's complicated
you and your wife yeah you and your
brothers or your sister you and yourself
you know how can you make space for
yourself now it's two of us so it's
there's less and there's more at the
same time it's less lusty but is more
right yeah there's more variety there's
more inspiration there's more tension
there's eight of testicle right yeah
yeah and but that's why it's so much
improvisation is done in the soloing
context right I mean how often do we get
five six seven people literally
improvising well very difficult but if
you get five or six different functions
you can get it yeah okay five or six of
them are playing in the same so same
functional space role it's very hard for
that to sound good unless that's the
point of it right then it can sound
great you know it'd just be this is a
texture of five or six people soloing
and you've also played with country
artists with rock-and-roll artists I
only found out last night when I was
anticipating this interview that you did
a whole album of Eric Clapton right it
was in we were playing blues yeah well
there's a common language here's a
common language is it's we our language
is so much more common than the language
we spoke with yeah cool right I mean in
what some I like Eric who loves blues
and it studied it and played it he said
he we were gonna do King Oliver's band
orchestration with blues songs so
whether some of the basis of rock and
roll is blues yeah rock and roll started
as shuffles that Count Basie's Orchestra
would play which became played by Lewis
join his band and uh then they don't do
the doing the don't--it don't--it
don't--it um did it went on to be that
later it became segregated in America
and it stood for white but that had
nothing to do with the music I remember
you know so I was growing up seventies
and eighties just a little bit after you
and II Living Colour of course and I was
a huge fan and I was like shocked to
learn that here is a rock-and-roll hard
rock band they were all African American
and people objected to that they're like
what are these African Americans to play
in rock and roll
what where did you come from isn't that
where it all originated yeah you know I
mean I don't even I don't leave me okay
so many different kind of people used to
have a friend you would say people say
at this you say there's a lot of people
a lot of people people say things yeah
they do yeah I remember Vernon Reid I
think never and Reeves the guitarist in
color yeah yeah yeah yeah in New York in
the 80s that's right exactly yeah and
now you uh you waited into hot water
recently right talking about hip hop
it's not hot water to me that's it's
good to like the hot water but so what
do you what are your feelings about hip
hop for those I know I was not speaking
of hip hop as a feel I was talking more
specifically the use of certain words
that I don't like right to be mainstream
words yeah I first started saying that
in 1987
now it's 2018 so the public has made
this decision they like that they want
that they let's not forget the minstrel
show lasted for a hundred years yeah if
you count eight eighteen forty to the
end of amos and andy there's a taste in
our country for that i don't share that
taste right so if it's if it gets me in
hot water because i say i don't share it
and you want to truncate what i'm saying
to be a blanket indictment of hip hop
and make it seem irrational
it's nothing you can do about that for
I'm grown
you got to say what you think I'm okay
I'm a grown man right and and I believe
that those words are destructive and
they have been destructive because
they've been out here for thirty years
they're not didn't just get out here the
nation has chosen they like that okay I
have to live with that but I don't have
to like it so you think it's a course
inning I think would you think yeah we
all think so
yeah do is look at we don't want to be
attacked but we all think something so
you're there is socially conscious
hip-hop there's poetry in hip hop's but
I'm not talking right yeah I'm not
talking about that Cup yeah exactly and
I'm not talking about it itself in a
blanket in any type of blanket kind of
crazy on intelligent way yeah whatever
it is this unintelligent it does not
account for the fact that there are many
different kinds of a thing I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
what is in the mainstream from a
linguistic stand and I'm not even coming
on it musically which I I'm qualified to
but I'm not that's not what I speak
about you're not gonna qualify right now
and I'm not gonna comment about it no
because it doesn't matter as the
direction that all of our music is going
in of a kind of way of being produced in
a way of being treated as a product in
to sit to segregate hip-hop from
everything else is unfair
that's very good point I mean it doesn't
hip-hop doesn't create the universe
around it right it's the other way
around
no so but but what I speak about is very
specifically about certain languages
that I did not like when it was first
around sure then I was young so
sometimes I see universe well you just
old guy who was look I was saying this
before you were born and uh once again
the nation has clearly spoken it likes
that yeah but I knew it liked it when if
it my mama told me something when she
realized when it stumbled into all of
that talk about the words I say I don't
like come people [ __ ] and all that my
mother said it's gonna get unlimited
resources now yeah I mean I I feel I
like hip-hop when it's good I went in
and of course whether it's good is up to
me right is it is for anybody right it
is for everybody I some of the classic
albums from the some of the early ones
like I can't listen to its heart right
and it's kind of a shame it's up to each
person and in the once again what we
think about it has no impact one who
likes it right we're not judges like we
don't we don't have the opportunity or
the ability to pass a sentence on it and
keep people from making their records or
this is a democracy well we can make
them think maybe yeah but I've been
talking about it for years I don't think
anybody thought about people are making
money with it and it's a national
pastime it's not
something to do with black people oh
yeah no not all it's like a tremendous
national taste for this type of imagery
yeah and not just in hip hop seriously
right
not just in hip hop I'm not a fan of
that right not saying I don't think it
should exist I don't think it should be
a mainstream right so so um even
qualifying it more if you want to go
somewhere and get stuff a we always had
stuff deals like that
Kendrick Lamar just won the Pulitzer
Prize and music you were the first is
that right you were the first winner of
the Pulitzer Prize of music which is not
classical at all I think so yeah yeah
yeah that was a great thing and you know
it's I I don't know a lot about that
world to me it's probably similar to the
Nobel Prize in the sense that there's a
lot of bad things about people chasing
prizes and things like that the prize
doesn't always go to the best person but
maybe it can help bring some attention
to some good work yeah I don't know the
prizes I don't I don't know prizes are
as serious is the rigor in which people
who hand out the prizes have about right
I think it's good for people who win
prizes in to to celebrate other people
and to show up his shows who tuxedos on
because it's fun I totally read it
doesn't mean anything larger than that I
don't I don't really look at I remember
when I want to Grammys my father mother
came out to Los Angeles and many other
people who should have won could play
better than me so after the Grammys I
was in a room with my father and my
father music how did Grammys he didn't
eat it you know he's not a guy who's
Hollywood kind of pop central he doesn't
care about any of that
yeah so he looked at me before I went
out in the street to parties hit yeah
you want two Grammys and I'm glad you
won you notice but when it's been in
losing then it seriously look at me is
it I hope you don't think that this
means you can play okay I was 21 I
understood exactly what he meant but I
think the whole point when he Grammys to
impress your parents lady what by me I
knew my father would not be yea
impressed but he was and he also was not
dousing me he wasn't treaded he would
just say man you know this stuff is not
really about no it's not but it's not
about nothing
yeah like you need to learn how to place
on you play okay but you're not the best
anything in a
any wig is in his way you'd have to know
him in no way was there like a negative
or a dousing I left actually I thought I
said man I know better than this you
know we go out on the party have a good
time so so has got a win these awards
yeah so I think I congratulate people
when they win awards and we keep it
moving it's gonna be another award next
year and is it's not I don't I don't
look at them one way or not look at them
I'm not I'm not critical or non-critical
what are your goals for your own music
in the future
to become better better musician write
better music become better at dealing
with the orchestra combine more forms
and do more things that are interesting
and innovative with a with a with with
jazz music and putting it become a
better soloist be more sophisticated in
my understanding of different forms
around the world and I'll just be more
dedicated and humbler about about my
development these are good these are
good goals for everybody but I'll say
also you know we're here at this
conference with you know there's people
talking about politics and science and
everything and and you were one of the
people up there on stage but you were
also one of the people in the audience
right you're listening yeah so your your
mind is growing as well as your I loved
it man I loved your presentation and uh
I love a lot of press I took a lot of
notes I'll go back and study read books
people say it it's a luxury to be able
to sit up in here unbelievably brilliant
people talk
you know everybody's dedicated they
think of all the dedication you've had
and your journey and another thing you
learned as a jazz musician is you know
that the creativity is all over the
world my father used to always say man
it's of many creative great people who
don't wear signs saying I'm creative I'm
great I'm smart and learn how to put
your radar up find it and listen and
believe me I'm on it I'm on this podcast
we aren't I'm putting it on in the
morning I'm checking you out I'm not
just saying it cuz I'm on it I mean that
I'm gonna I'm gonna go to love being
being educated about the things that you
taught my with the big s you have on and
I have thoroughly enjoyed myself
everything from new developing cities to
autism to the me to movement to to to
which you would talk about what Julie
was Tom I mean you know it was it's all
bizarre that's all interesting
copy did you have any or have you had
any special interest in science in
general or is this just you always loved
science when I was growing up yeah I
loved all of the science it's a lot of
love biology I always did pretty good as
a student and chemistry and yeah I loved
the sciences you know I told you I read
the dancing wooly masters years ago
uh-huh
and I am interested I need to to be
educated there's an infinite number of
things that we all need to learn right
now you don't that that's we're not
gonna run out of interesting things to
learn about right but we were having an
interesting conversation the other night
about entanglement quantum mechanics
right and maybe there's a connection
with jazz and fall in fact I mean it's a
it's almost a cliche I don't know if you
know Stephon Alexander do you know that
name he's a physics professor at
Dartmouth wrote a book yes the judge as
a physics I haven't read that book yet
but yeah a saxophone player yeah I know
him yeah yeah and I mean part of me like
you know we're trained it just like
you're trained to be a critic in music
we're trained in science to be skeptical
right someones make some grandiose
claims so the claim would be that you
know there is a at least an analogy
between how we already already talk
about waves and waves bumping into each
other clearly that's part of music
rhythm and so forth tone and and pitch
but there's also randomness right
there's probability and but it's not a
mess right there's probability in
quantum mechanics things don't exist
until you observe them bring them into
existence and maybe there is an analogy
that's useful there between that
unconscious so low that you're doing
that until you played the note it wasn't
there like you didn't write it out ahead
of time well all that our the the the
the I think that repetition is a way
that we can what do we control entropy
we we have to repeat things I was
talking with the artist and he was be
making me laugh he said I see the world
new every day and I create new things
every day I said when I equate that with
being on the run you stopped to smell
the roses you know we all we all have
things we're gonna do did we touch those
maybe we're gonna yeah that's part of
for being in a kind of system did but if
you're running you you're not doing a
lot of things that others say it's true
it's true and I think that we even
mentioned before the balance between
something different in something that
fits in that's right sort of what you're
looking for and that goes into what I
said about entropy in the sense that we
start with the universe that's simple we
end with the universe that's simple
entropy is going up on the wave is in
the middle we're entropy is middle and
complex structures are there and you
don't know what's gonna happen it's not
so simple that's in your fun right and
you do you saying you're trying to order
them in a way that you can order them to
understand whatever you can understand
yeah we try to understand bit by bit it
dry and but jazz gives you the
opportunity to understand slices of
reality not just from your perspective
now you understand it so much I call it
at the speed of instinct mm-hmm like how
fast is instinct man is fast that's fair
that speed yeah and you're playing in
that or not on the edge always of
instinct because it's always the present
moment present moment president won't
present and you you're trying to come in
that press like riding a wave right now
you're just going on that wave and
there's other people the presence of
other people make make you all have as
like a multi it's like a Hydra it's like
is and you're perceiving them and you're
perceiving the form and you're
perceiving and you're perceiving
audience and they're perceiving you and
it's all going on going on going on
going on going on boom then there's over
then you can listen to it and assess it
when you're playing it you can right I
mean do you ever just trance out you're
just like playing your knee you don't
even notice what's going I'm always like
that I'm only listening like I'm
listening so intensely and trying to
just it's like you're just looking at
something in the space but this is Dizzy
Gillespie told me he has Lula's
Armstrong called me once four o'clock in
the morning Los Angeles it are you up I
said of course I'm up
he said man up you know I remember I
went to the ophthalmologist and he said
when you want to play low look low when
you're playing middle register playing
when you want to play high look up high
and it did he told me say man I started
doing I said well i told asked it was
armstrong one time I said pops why are
you always looking up high what are you
looking for and he said pops told him I
don't know brother dears but I always
find it
[Laughter]
today he's looking up there where his
stuff is on sometimes I tease musician
we're on the bandstand and I see them
looking at it and I know what they're
looking at and I'll say look at it you
know look at it okay cuz they look at me
when you look at you looking at a point
in space you know look at anything but
you're trying to just hear and perceive
everything that's going on and order it
I figure out where do I fit into this
and what it's such unbelievably exciting
thing when there's when it's done well
and it's you know I wrote a book about
time and the nature of time and how
clocks tell time and everything and our
bodies are full of clocks right our
bodies are full of things that do the
same thing in a rhythm over and over
again whether it's our heartbeat or a
breathing or our nerves bouncing back
and forth and I think that really good
music whether it's jazz or classical or
whatever it's sort of it feeds into that
and draws from it right it's like the
rhythms inside us come out in some
interesting way I would love to see
although I would love to get in the in
the I'm gonna get the book but is it
what you talk about all the different
clocks that are in the body I mean if I
looked at it would it give me an
understanding of what they are no but I
have friends who know that stuff yeah
that physicists but yeah the body is so
far too complicated for me but it goes
into you know some things can be taught
and some things are just kind of India I
don't I don't want to say they're you
know inherited but they come from places
we don't know
yeah it's a thing but doing jazz we
called it a thing yeah hey I got that
thing did anyone ever did I sometimes
for the podcast interview
neuroscientists did anyone ever try to
like put you in a brain scanner while
you're playing somebody was talking
about doing it with a band yeah but we
we didn't do it I would love to do it
well David Popples is that I'll hooked
you up if you want to do it I would love
to do so because his thing is there's
different ways of looking inside the
head to see what your brain is doing now
I mean this is stuff that we've
developed over the last couple decades
right so you don't need to do surgery
uh-huh
to peek in of the brain that you can do
an MRI which will show you where in the
brain things are happening but it's very
slow so if you're even if you're just
talking forget about improvising forget
about playing fast do you you don't know
when it's happening but what you can
also do what's happening in the brain
right are these chemicals zooming around
and they make little magnetic fields
that pop outside your head and they can
measure those right away man I would
love to see that what it would be like
for a band really playing and I know
improv I would love my students to do it
and I told you I want you to talk to my
students they would love it got great
students Julie oh I would love to do
that yeah yeah and you know I think it's
coming because brain computer interfaces
I think this is a common theme for me
but I think that you know one of the
things that's gonna change the future is
our ability to forget about our fingers
just go right from the brain to the
machine and go back and forth and it
might be very very slow and might you
know be a hundred years from now so
that's okay I'm a physicist hundred
years nothing right but I think that
yeah well it'll be interesting to see
how we learn about music we learn about
what it means
some people less musical like I can't
sing a note but you know I love
listening to other people it's great so
which in Marsalis thank you so much for
this a fantastic conversation it is such
a pleasure to have so much respect and
us honor and pleasure and keep the
journey going yes sir that's what we
both doing all right thanks that yes sir
thank
[Music]
you
[Music]